buenas como están cuando yo era pequeña
el niño más bullying de la clase me
decía la sociedad protectora de animales
esto era porque a mí me indignaba
muchísimo que le hiciera daño a mis
compañeros los que no se podían defender
y entonces no me podía quedar de brazos
cruzados cuando crecí y llegué al
colegio mis apodos cambiaron de repente
me convertí en el capitán planeta a la
brasa árboles y esto era porque andaba
detrás de mis compañeros y compañeras
para que apagarán la luz para que
recogieran los residuos para que
reciclarán etcétera esa pasión por el
medio ambiente la naturaleza la mantuve
y tomé la decisión de estudiar
ingeniería ambiental pero me pasaba que
mientras algunas de mis compañeras y
compañeras se apasionan por la química
por la física por el diseño de plantas
desde el tratamiento a mí lo que me
interesaba era el vínculo entre las
personas y el medio ambiente nuestra
calidad de vida y el entorno que nos
rodea
y como genera que tengamos un buen nivel
de vida
todo esto tuvo sentido en el 2007 cuando
fui como voluntaria a el precario los
diques esto fue la primera vez que yo
fui a un precario en mi vida y conocí a
estos niños y niñas fui con la fundación
techo
y estos niños y niñas corrían por la
calle sin zapatos por la calle también
cubrían las aguas negras había residuos
por todos lados tomaban agua de
españoles que se llenaban con agua que
venía de tuberías hechizas vivían en
casas de lata en la ladera del río y si
el río se crecía ahí en la casa y me di
cuenta que muchos de los elementos que
rodeaban estas familias que eran se
podían solucionar con soluciones
ambientales y de gestión ambiental
ingeniería ambiental eran factores que
estaban presentando la pobreza la
condición de pobreza de estas personas
entonces de repente su situación
socioeconómica tenía mucho que ver con
el entorno ambiental que los rodea 2
hoy les voy a hablar de ambiente de
personas y de ciudades y por qué las
ciudades son un lugar óptimo para
trabajar en mejorar el medio ambiente
pero también a la vez mejorar la calidad
de vida de las personas en particular
aquellas que son más vulnerables
hablemos de descarbonización esto es una
palabra un poco intimidante un poco
técnica que venimos escuchando
recientemente en los medios en el radio
etcétera
pero para hablar de descarbonización
tenemos que hablar de cambio climático
imaginemos que el cambio climático es un
avión que avanza esas aceleradamente y
descontroladamente a chocar contra una
ciudad sabemos haciendo cálculos más o
menos en cuánto tiempo va a caer
sabemos haciendo cálculos más o menos
cuántos daños puede generar si no
hacemos nada entonces tenemos que hacer
algo hay un tipo de medidas que se
llaman descarbonización que le podemos
llamar así en la jerga climática que es
tratar de desacelerar ese avión tratar
de reducir los componentes que ahorita
están ocasionando el cambio climático
pero también hay otro tipo de medidas
que le llamamos adaptación sabiendo que
ese avión va a caer sí o sí como nos
preparamos para que cuando caiga tenga
la menor cantidad de impactos posibles
pero ese es cuando diseñamos estas
políticas o tratamos de desarrollar
proyectos para descarbonizar o para
adaptar se nos olvida las personas hay
personas en ese avión hay personas en
esa ciudad y podemos diseñar soluciones
que generen más desigualdad podemos
generar soluciones que dejen atrás a
aquellas personas más vulnerables y eso
lo que tenemos que tratar de evitar
si yo les hablo a ustedes de
descarbonización sin darles mucho
contexto que imagen se le viene a la
cabeza
quién pensó en el oso polar
quién pensó en paneles solares energías
limpias etcétera
alguien pensó en bosques que están
captando el carbono liberando oxígeno
pero que nos falta en estas imágenes
nos faltan personas
cuando hablamos de descarbonización yo
me imagino una calle llena de personas
que puede caminar tranquilamente bajo la
sombra de los árboles donde puede
respirar aire limpio donde puede
interactuar unos con los otros
sentirse segura y disfrutar de la ciudad
también me puedo imaginar una huerta
urbana comunitaria donde no solo
interactuamos con los vecinos sino que
también cultivamos hortalizas frutas
vegetales que ya no tenemos que
trasladarnos a otro lugar al
supermercado a la feria a la pulpa para
comprarlas sino que están ahí y estamos
aportando a la biodiversidad de nuestra
comunidad porque los polinizadores
también se alimentan de esa zona también
podemos cultivar los de manera orgánica
y no estamos utilizando fertilizantes
nitrogenados que liberan emisiones que
contribuyen al cambio climático
y descarbonización también es y debe ser
pensar en todas esas personas que el día
de hoy caminan andan en bicicleta
utilizan medios de transporte que no se
habilitan por la ciudad personas con
discapacidad que al día de hoy no pueden
darle la vuelta a la cuadra porque no
hay aceras que lo habiliten
porque nuestras ciudades están diseñadas
para el carro y no todo el mundo tiene
el poder adquisitivo de tener un carro y
hay veces ni siquiera ha de andar en bus
entonces una ciudad descarbonizada debe
ser inclusiva y debe habilitar que
podamos caminar y podamos andar en bus
en bicicleta en silla de ruedas etcétera
lo humano de la descarbonización es
crucial pero también vengo a hablarles
de lo urbano y por qué porque es
ciudades cuando hablamos de
descarbonización
donde hay ciudades hay gente esto es un
principio milenario y donde hay gente
hay emisiones estas emisiones son las
que están contribuyendo a que el cambio
climático se acelera que ese avión venga
a chocar contra nosotros y más del 60
por ciento de las emisiones del mundo
hoy se generan en las ciudades
de dónde vienen estas emisiones
recientemente se publicó un estudio en
el que hicieron los inventarios de gases
de efecto invernadero en 6 cantones de
nuestro país y se identificó que en la
mayor cantidad de las emisiones viene de
sector transporte el sector energía
sector vecinos procesos industriales y
agricultura transporte mayoritariamente
de vehículos privados como muchas de las
personas que hoy vinieron acá usualmente
una persona máximo 2 en un vehículo esos
son los que más se están aportando a
contaminar nuestras ciudades energía
estacionaria hornos calderas en la
industria por ejemplo los los
generadores de emergencia cuando se va
la luz que utilizan diésel las cocinas
de gas que usamos para cocinar eso
genera emisiones los residuos
principalmente los residuos orgánicos
cuando compramos frutas y vegetales si
no nos las comemos y se pudrieron
generan emisiones
la crisis climática hoy día ya está
generando impactos tangibles e
irreversibles y va a seguir generando
estos impactos en nuestra calidad de
vida esto no es en otro lado del mundo
esto es en san jose costa rica
estas fotos ilustran como ya estamos
viendo estos impactos pero en los
próximos años vamos a vivir más impactos
el 77 por ciento de las ciudades van a
experimentar cambios significativos en
su clima el 2050 22 por ciento de esas
van a vivir climas a los cuales nunca
antes se han enfrentado una ciudad que
tal vez es casi desértica y que hay un
poquito de lluvia una vez al año ahora
va a tener tanta lluvia que si no se
prepara puede sufrir inundaciones
constantemente
64 de las ciudades que van a enfrentar
estos retos son del trópico entonces san
jose costa rica es una ciudad que se
tiene que ir adaptando y preparando para
cuando ese avión llegue
y si les estoy hablando de lo urbano
porque les está enseñando una foto de
una zona rural
el cambio climático nos impacta a todos
entonces en las zonas rurales también se
están sufriendo los impactos tal vez una
persona que por décadas venía cultivando
papas por ejemplo en esta foto empieza a
tener menores rendimientos porque ese
cultivo en específico requiere cierto
clima cierta temperatura cierta
precipitación y ya eso no está haciendo
igual que hace 10 años y empieza a
terminar el rendimientos una persona que
vivió por décadas en la misma comunidad
ahora de repente se está viendo
desplazada porque se inunda y se inunda
y se inunda y ya no se puede vivir ahí
otras se están viendo desplazadas porque
ya no hay agua entonces muchas de estas
personas que terminan haciendo buscando
oportunidades en las ciudades y muchas
llegan en en condiciones de
vulnerabilidad y empieza el ciclo
similar al que les conté de los niños y
las niñas que vivían en los diques
entonces de repente los impactos del
cambio climático en las zonas rurales no
generan aún más brechas sociales en las
ciudades y tenemos que buscar solucionar
eso
ante eso quiero que hagamos una pausa y
pensemos en que esto no se trata de
salvar el mundo tratar salvar al medio
ambiente qué es lo que más o menos nos
vienen diciendo hace mucho tiempo que
esto es un problema ambiental eso se
trata de salvarnos a nosotros mismos si
la humanidad se acaba el medioambiente
se regenerará evolucionará y habrá algo
nuevo sin nosotros esto se trata de
salvarnos a nosotros mismos y cuando
pensamos en que si bien una crisis
climática y nos tenemos que salvar
quiénes son los que se pueden salvar
primero y mejor quiénes tienen mayor
cantidad de recursos quienes tienen
mayor poder adquisitivo entonces tenemos
que procurar tener las salvaguardas
suficientes para no dejar a nadie atrás
porque cuando hay impactos ambientales
los más vulnerables son los que los
sufren más
vivimos en un momento de crisis y el
cambio climático es una crisis pero como
yo soy optimista y creo que todos
ustedes también porque están en un télex
tenemos que ver una crisis como una
oportunidad y esta oportunidad es de
transformar la manera en que venimos
haciendo las cosas transformar nuestra
economía transformar nuestros procesos
industriales transformar la manera en
que planificamos nuestras ciudades para
que sean diferentes
entonces qué beneficios puede traer
descarbonizar una ciudad
pensemos en positivo
recientemente se aprobó un plan nacional
de descarbonización que tiene medidas a
corto mediano y largo plazo para que
transformemos nuestra economía hacia una
economía descarbonizada entonces plantea
propuestas para el sector transporte
sector agro sector residuos sector
industria energía etcétera y plantea
medidas a diferentes escalas pero si
pensamos en las ciudades
como como sé cómo se come esto en una
ciudad si tenemos una ciudad que tiene
buen transporte público que ese
transporte público está articulado con
redes de ciclovías y redes de aceras que
son accesibles para personas con
discapacidad que también están
acompañados por espacios públicos
arborizados por verde en las ciudades y
no tener que salir de la ciudad para
buscarlo si son ciudades en las que en
un mismo edificio que además es
sostenible puedo ir al banco vivir e ir
al súper sin tener que trasladarme
tantos lugares de repente empezamos a
ver ciudades más limpios ciudades más
agradables más saludables más verdes más
coloridas más biodiversas menos
contaminadas menos congestionadas menos
hostiles
menos estresantes ciudades más
silenciosas imagínense que podríamos
escuchar una ciudad si no oímos el ruido
de los motores que podríamos escuchar
ciudad más sociables porque
interactuamos más adaptadas al cambio
climático más atractivas para inversión
porque donde la gente quiere vivir la
gente quiere invertir y esto genera
oportunidades de empleo nichos de
negocio dinamización de la economía yo
no sé ustedes pero yo querría vivir en
una ciudad así
y eso es posible vemos muchas ciudades
en el mundo que ya han hecho esa
transición y no sucedió de la noche a la
mañana eso toma tiempo por supuesto pero
si hay varios elementos comunes que
tenemos que pensar para trabajar hacia
eso primero que todo reconocer reconocer
que hay elementos que hoy en día nos
duelen nos duelen las muertes nos duele
la contaminación nos duele la mala salud
en nuestras ciudades nos duelen los
precios del petróleo etcétera que luego
grupos de presión se organicen y
empiezan a presionar para que las cosas
cambien y esa presión no necesariamente
son solo protestas también puede ser una
mano amiga para hacer alianzas
público-privadas para apoyar al sector
público para tomar decisiones y por
último acciones transformadoras que los
tomadores de decisión no hagan acciones
tímidas sutiles pequeñas sino que de
verdad digan eso es lo que tenemos que
hacer vamos a transformar la manera en
que estamos planificando nuestro país
nuestra economía nuestras ciudades
si la descarbonización es una
oportunidad para tener ciudades más
verdes y resilientes si la
descarbonización nos puede ayudar a
tener ciudades más competitivas
si nos puede ayudar a tener mejor
calidad de vida entonces lo que les
propongo el día de hoy es conoce unamos
para transformar nuestras ciudades el
país y el mundo porque el momento para
actuar es ahora muchas gracias
[Aplausos]